is it true that you actually tattooed
someone that we're all obsessed with his
name right might rhyme with like neat
havenon yes so crazy story I tattooed
Pete Davidson Miley cyers Chris red all
backstage in Pete's dressing room no way
oh my God what was that Vibe like the
vibe was so chill so relaxed and I'm
like I could like hear Miley performing
and then right after she came in in like
the full outfit like hey like tattoo me
in my leg like yes get one get one on
yeah let's do it so it was so cool such
a good experience that is such a thank
you for transporting me to that dressing
room and moment cuz I wasn't there but
in my fantasies I can now visit
it